so jen sackey the white house press
secretary uh
last week she did one of the greatest
gaslights of all time this lady
where she implied that it's the
republicans she said sonny the victim
some might say it's the republicans
who've been wanting to defund the police
complete and utter nonsensical
[ __ ] well she's continuing her
string of complete and utter nonsensical
[ __ ]
uh at her most recent press conference
where now she's saying that joe biden
ran
on funding the police and law and order
now i have no recollection
and again i will go into the youtube
comments section somebody
find me the video but that's what she's
saying right now i have no recollection
of joe biden ever saying he wanted to
fund the police the whole
democratic base was calling for defund
the police and we've got the video we're
going to show it to you again
but first here's saki and the president
ran on
most importantly did not run on
defending the police he's always opposed
defunding the police
i'll also note because you've asked this
question before or a few times over the
last several days
that when we talk about uh individuals
in congress and their support for
funding or
opposition to funding for the police i
think what the american people are most
focused on is how people vote
what their record is which is a public
record and i will note that
well the president ran on and won the
most votes of any candidate in history
in a platform of boosting funding for
law enforcement
after republicans spent decades trying
to cut the cops program
which again is public record we don't
need to under
under uh undervalue the intelligence of
the american people
the president ran on increasing that
funding it's in his budget
in president trump's budget he
significantly cut that so that's a
change
oh i don't like this lady everything she
does
is undervaluing the intelligence of the
american people but let's get the exact
quote
i've got the quote for you that she said
there in case you missed it she said the
president ran on and won the most
votes of any candidate in the history of
the platform of boosting
funding for law enforcement after
republicans spent
decades trying to cut the cops program
what what are you talking about i have
no recollection i watched
every single debate i am fairly well
versed in the political machinations of
the day i am a man of the media
i have no recollection of biden talking
about boosting policing
uh complaining that the republicans were
cutting funding for the police i have no
i have no evidence that republicans were
cutting the police anywhere cup
it's been the complete reverse but if
you don't believe me
steve scalise tweeted out this
compilation video it's a little bit
different from the one we showed you
last week i think you'll enjoy it
why use the word defund why use the word
define yes i support the defund movement
this is the word that's coming from the
streets
there's some issues that we ask police
to do like mental health issues or
policing in schools and all the rest
that perhaps we can shuffle some of that
money around
we will not be increasing our police
budget we propose
to redirect over seven million dollars
from the police bureau
the use of storm troopers under the
guise of law and order
we've got to re-examine what we're doing
with american taxpayer dollars
we need to completely dismantle the
minneapolis police department
the minneapolis city council voting nine
to three in favor of disbanding the
police department
today in new york mayor bill de blasio
announced a plan to defund the nypd
i want people to understand that we are
committed to shifting resources
so cities across the country are seeing
a major spike in violent crime now
violent crime is way up and claiming
victims here in los angeles at a rate
we haven't seen in decades crime surging
in democrat-led
cities that slashed police funding last
year murders
up 46 percent a scary scene earlier this
week in new york city showed a shootout
in the middle of the street during broad
daylight the white house trying to shift
blame because crime is out of control
fighting administration is desperately
trying to spin a new narrative
now it's the republicans who support
defunding the police
democrats embrace this crazy radical
idea of defunding the police last summer
all right so you know that war on
reality i'm always talking about and how
if you have friends and family that
watch cnn and read the new york times
and washington post or whatever else it
is they live in a very different
reality well that's it right there so
perhaps
show them that little two-minute montage
we'll we'll clip it
i'll put it on the twitter and you can
send it to them
and then you can check them into a
mental institution because the cognitive
dissonance that they will have the
inability to deal with reality as it is
not the narrative that they like will
probably snap their brains
and then you know you'll have to visit
them once a week and it's a whole
situation i get it i get it that's why
people don't want to do it
the line that i liked in there though
was nancy pelosi because i did not know
this
storm troopers under the guise of law
and order i mean if we're getting storm
troopers involved like are we talking
about clone soldiers are we going back
to camino and
making that whole thing happen or are we
going to kidnap children when they're
very young
and turn them into super soldiers you
know
okay you got my point guys uh yeah it's
just a lie saki's a liar the democrats
are liars
biden did not run on boosting funding to
the police and yes it is true
that in democrat-run cities all hell is
breaking loose related to violence look
what's going on in chicago can we get
the numbers from chicago
let's do it it's monday we should have a
fun like
like 70s game show theme song play when
i get this let's get the murders in
chicago today how many how many it's
80 so there were 80 i'm guessing
shootings not not actual murders we're
going to get the numbers
88 shootings how many were fatal
14 dead 88 shootings this weekend in
chicago
the mayor of chicago by the way is
laurie lightfoot
who is the mayor who said that she won't
be interviewed uh
except by black and brown journalists
she also we were going to play the clip
today but we decided not to do it a few
days ago she was interviewed
and she said that 99 of the criticism of
her
is because her critics are racist uh i
am not racist lori lightfoot but you
were an incompetent buffoon and 14
people in your city
died this weekend and 88 were shot so
you see you might have a problem there
and it has nothing to do with me being
racist